let's add these two mixed numbers 2 and
5 13 plus 7 and 6 13. and the way i like
to think about in my head i like to
separate separate out the mixed numbers
into the whole number component and the
fractional component so we can rewrite 2
and 5 13 as 2
as 2 plus
5 over 13 plus 5 over 13 and then we can
write that plus and then 7 and 6 13 we
can rewrite as plus 7 plus 6 13
plus 6 13.
6 13. so all i did is i rewrote this and
i essentially expanded out i broke up
the mixed numbers into their whole
number parts and their fractional parts
and then what i like to do is i like to
add the whole number parts so this 2
plus this 7 so i'll do that so i'll do
the 2 plus 7 over here i'll add those up
and to that i will add the fractional
parts so to that i will add the 5 13
5 13 to the six thirteenths
six thirteenths so if we add the whole
number parts two plus seven
is nine and the fractional parts they
already have the same denominator in
this problem 5 13 plus 6 13 same
denominator you're going to get 11 13
11 13. 5 plus 6 is 11. so you get 9
plus 11 13 well that's just the same
thing as 9 and 11
13. and we are done